Speaker 1: We have some incredible new
video of our friend Donnie O'Sullivan.
Or do I never remember if it's Donnie or Donnie
O'Sullivan? He's a CNN reporter. He's excellent.
He went to Arizona over the weekend. Now in
Arizona over the weekend, there were two different
things going on. One, vice former Vice President
Mike Pence was campaigning for the challenger to
carry Lake. I forget that candidate's name. And
Donald Trump was campaigning for Kerry like.
Donnie O'Sullivan went to Arizona,
interviewed the Trump supporters,
and it is as bad as anything that I
have ever seen. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 4: He didn't know it's.
Speaker 5: Since you.
Speaker 4: You just did lose.
Speaker 5: Do you believe the election was stolen?
Yes. Do you have faith in elections now? No.
Do you believe the 2020 election was stolen?
No, I don't.
Speaker 3: Believe the 2020.
Speaker 6: Election was stolen. I
believe that there are aspects of
the 2020 election that were unfair.
Speaker 5: In Arizona, a Republican
Party at odds with itself, Trump and Pence
holding competing events were two very
different understandings of reality.
Speaker 3: We need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig
it or steal it, even if they try.
Speaker 5: At Trump's rally, a bonfire of
Conspiracy Theories. Have you watched the January
six hearings? I have. But you think?
Speaker 4: I think they're a bunch of
bull quite well because you have both sides.
Or are you getting one side of the story?
Speaker 5: You mean like the
side that attacked the Capitol?
Speaker 4: You really believe that happened?
Speaker 5: I was there.
Speaker 4: Okay. I have a lot
of people that were there.
Speaker 1: Guys, she has people help.
Speaker 4: And and saw things that
it wasn't what they say it was.
Speaker 5: But there's been hundreds
of Trump supporters now charged or pled guilty.
Speaker 4: So. And do you think it's right for
those people to have those people in jail and
not get any justice in our American system.
Speaker 1: All of a sudden? You know,
it's funny. There's been no greater event
that has inspired the right to demand criminal
justice reform, pretrial detention reform.
There's been nothing it's been 40 years with the
left has been talking about this. And all of a
sudden, these arguably domestic terrorists are
arrested and jailed. And now all of a sudden,
the right is saying, we're not treating people
in the justice system very well. Incredible.
Speaker 4: Kid.
Speaker 5: Do you think it
was right that they attacked the Capitol?
Speaker 4: I don't. They didn't do.
Speaker 1: That. Nobody attacked
it, guys. It's all fake.
Speaker 4: Inside your body.
Speaker 5: The vast conspiracy theory
that those who stormed the Capitol were not Trump
supporters as widespread here. Have you guys been
watching the January six hearings at all? No, no.
Speaker 6: No. We saw it when it all went down.
And then we saw like a lot of the BLM
and Antifa people in the building as.
Speaker 1: It was and.
Speaker 3: Trefor. Well, and.
Speaker 6: And it's just it's just.
Speaker 5: Nonsense. But I think like
800 people now have been charged, right? Yeah.
And the Black Lives Matter are Antifa. Yeah.
Speaker 4: They're not charged, but that doesn't
mean they have not been brought into court.
Speaker 1: Right.
So here's what happened. The real perpetrators
of the January six riots were Black Lives Matter
Antifa in disguise as Trump supporters.
They have not actually been charged.
The people that have been charged are the real
Trump supporters who didn't do anything. But okay,
they're on video doing stuff, but
they're actually Black Lives Matter.
Not really Trump supporters. But the Black Lives
Matter people have been charged, and the ones
charged are the Trump supporters who are victims.
But it looks like they're on video doing stuff.
But it's not really Trump supporters. It's Antifa.
You see how it's just an endless circle. The
circle never ends and it's like a moebius strip.
Speaker 4: Due process because
they have not been arrested.
Speaker 6: Hunter Biden hasn't been arrested.
Speaker 5: Trump has told lies about the
election in that he said he didn't really lose.
Do you think that all the lies about the
election are damaging for American democracy?
Speaker 4: Do you believe he lied?
Speaker 5: Do you not?
Speaker 4: No, I do not. I don't know why he won.
Speaker 5: But these are no longer fringe ideas.
A majority of Republicans do not believe Biden
legitimately won the election. Hey, guys, any of
you want to talk to us? The proud boys who Trump
once infamously told to stand back and stand by
now a regular fixture outside his events.
Then he probably is going to talk to us today.
Now, you're watching January 6th hearings. No,
nothing except CNN. Right? CNN fans. Okay, thanks,
guys. The former president here to campaign for
a ticket of conspiracy theory spouting candidates
who say they would have overturn the
results of the 2020 election in Arizona.
Like Carrie Lake, candidate for governor.
Speaker 4: I know for a fact we will no
longer accept rigged elections.
Who's with me on that right here?
Speaker 5: Campaigning for Republican rival.
Speaker 3: And Arizona needs Karen Taylor
Robeson in the state house.
Speaker 5: Here we met some
Republicans who are Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Now, here, this is also
interesting because it's not like these are
reasonable people, but they've had it with Trump.
Speaker 6: I voted for Trump twice. If Mike
Pence runs, I'm voting for Mike Pence. Okay,
so why is that? I just think that, you know,
everyone seen the January six committee.
I he stood up for democracy that day. You know,
he's like, I'm not leaving the Capitol because
I need to be here. And he was the one that
was making phone calls to the military.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this is fascinating because
I'm with you that compared to the Trump people,
this guy seems eminently reasonable. But remember,
Pence didn't really do anything. Pence didn't have
a choice. The thing that Trump wanted Pence to do,
Pence didn't have the power to do. So now they're
considering Pence a hero simply because he didn't
overtly try to do something he had no right to do.
And that seems reasonable by comparison.
Speaker 6: Trying to fix the situation
while Trump was crying in the dining room.
Speaker 5: But even among this crowd, there is
sympathy for Trump's election lies and support for
a 2024 run. You're about to see Pence speak here.
Trump's not a big fan of him right now.
Speaker 4: I understand that.
I hear that he could have not certified
those results pending all the claims of
the fraud. Ron, I wish you would have done that.
Speaker 5: Pence had no legal basis to do that.
Also among those here, Rusty Bowers, a lifelong
Republican and speaker of the Arizona State House
here, talking to a lot of people in here today
who said they're not even they're not watching
the January six hearings. They still believe
in lies about the 2020 election. How do you
what would be your message to them?
Speaker 7: I have no message for them. I
can't help them. You don't want to look. You don't
want to see. And then you won't see them. But
I've seen enough to know. And I know that all
the people right in this room have done their
best to count everything and do it. All right.
Speaker 5: He testified before the January six
committee about Trump's efforts to get him to
overturn the 2020 results in his state. What is
these conspiracy theories, these lies about the
election, about democracy? What is that doing to
trust? In this case, it destroys it.
Speaker 7: It destroys it. We've
got to let things go.
Speaker 5: What would
need to change for you to
have faith in us democracy?
I don't trust our government. First of all,
period. And if you don't have fair elections.
Speaker 3: What good are they?
Speaker 5: Do you ever worry that you're
wrong? Do you ever worry that? Oh, absolutely.
You're worried that Trump has sold you a lie.
Speaker 4: If you start researching and believe
that you're the one who's wrong and that you're
crazy. Which I did do. Okay, maybe I'm
wrong. And maybe I am being brainwashed
and believing something that someone's telling me.
But then you go in and look the other direction
and you find lies. After lie is after lies.
Speaker 1: Right. She suspected she was
being lied to. But then she's like, the other
side is lying even more. I guess. So this is
these are very resistant to change beliefs.
And there is going to be a real battle for the
Republican Party. If you look at the polling, you
already see it. And we're going to look at some of
that polling later this week, probably or maybe
next week. This is going to be a real battle in
not only 22, but in particular in 2024. But look
at the folks that are being fought over and that
really should make us think, wow, this is
not exactly a group, to put it politely,
that is necessarily going to fairly and soberly
and calmly evaluate the claims being being made
by the Trump and anti-Trump sides of the
Republican Party and come to some kind of
empirical conclusion. And that should
scare all of us. We're going to continue
covering these types of interviews. Really,
really good job there by Donie O'Sullivan